I'm actually I'm losing weight I've lost
a lot of weight recently um cuz I just
broke up with my boyfriend
no no that's just how I do it that's how
I do it you know when I'm not with you I
look amazing if I'm in a relationship
with you and you see me doing air squats
and situps
it's over okay I'm about to leave you
because it's not for you okay it's for
the next victim
the one I really want and when he falls
in love with a thin version of Who I am
I'm gonna eat and I'm gonna get really
fat I can't wait I'm gonna get that kind
of fat like like if they ever have to
move me they have to think about it
[Applause]
that kind of fad and then I must sit on
that man
i'ma sit on with my fat ass and I'm just
gonna watch him struggle and I'm gonna
tell him you ain't going nowhere and
that's how I keep I like this men who
are lapped some of the men will never
laugh at this because they're like that
happened to me okay and that's just not
funny I mean today I'm free but what a
journey out from under her fat ass my
last boyfriend was white that's
something we're doing he had never been
around black people that happens we're
not everywhere we're not I go places and
I ask are we here nothing comes back
like I did a show one time we weren't at
that show and so I asked that question I
was like are there black people here and
this woman's answer was great she was
like oh they are all over the place that
is not how you answer that question
but yeah he hadn't had the experience
and so it was a fun relationship like
culture culturally like I would catch
him sometimes like just staring like at
my hair you know just looking like he
never really dealt with even look so I
told him one time I said touch this one
time he just had it you pat my fro and
he reshaped it and I was looking like
Frederick Douglass that day good
something you need to google who
Frederick Douglass is just a hint not a
rapper okay so I actually I may be going
back to black it's uh you know it's time
now to bring it back to the community
now I'll help some young brothers in
yeah I went on a date with the brother
black I just in case I want something I
don't want you to leave here like wow
you know what she really gave up
she's dating a brother and that would be
a weird give up wouldn't it like you
know what the family already knows you
let's just do this
but I did I went on a date with the
brother but I was um he was too young
for me and I could tell because we were
out on the date we went to the Central
Park we were walking around and this
older black woman she saw us and she
kept it real she's like now you know you
ain't supposed to be with that little
boy she made me feel so guilty I thought
I said no this is a make-a-wish
Foundation I'm a dream come true baby
[Applause]